when i sit down and read
i'm i'm gaining more words hi steve
kaufman here and um today i want to talk
about reading
and language learning so if you enjoy
these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications if
you follow me on a podcast service
please leave a review
now
for those of you who have been following
my channel you know that i emphasize
listening and reading
as being the most important activities
for acquiring a language of course we
want to speak we eventually want to
speak a lot our goal is to speak we want
to speak well
but the emphasis should be on listening
and reading because it's something we
can do
whenever we want on our own and it
really does help our brain become
familiar with the language
if you want to read up on it you should
check out language acquisition
with stephen krashen k-r-a-s-h-e-n
who is in my view the leading explainer
of how we learn languages
so i did a video on listening
in french
and it has been very well received and
so
uh i'm going to do videos on the subject
of listening
in other languages maybe spanish
japanese chinese let me know what you
would like to hear of course i can't
necessarily do it all that well in the
languages that i don't speak as well
but today i want to focus on reading
you'll notice in behind me is a new
backdrop it shows a bookshelf so i have
two backdrops i have my wooden plank
backdrop which is in behind
and i have my bookshelf
backdrop
because i love books so i love reading i
think reading is a phenomenal
technology
if we think that that humans did not
have the ability to read for most of our
existence as
i mean if you go back before homo
sapiens uh i mean for the amount of time
that
hominids or whatever they're called
have been on this earth during the whole
process of evolution there was no
reading and so all of a sudden
as humankind developed this technology
of representing
words and thought
through symbols which started however
many years ago
and i'm not going to go into the history
of writing but there have been many
writing systems
today in the world there are many
writing systems
all of a sudden humans our brains had to
develop this ability to convert
symbols
into meaning
into perhaps sound perhaps meaning
and
it's amazing that our brains have become
very good at doing this it's not a
simple task i think although i'm not a
any kind of a cognitive scientist
i find that if i want to
you know learn how to do something or
learn about anything reading is the
fastest way to get there
listening is great because i can do that
while doing other tasks reading i have
to basically commit myself to reading
this thing but with reading i can take
notes
and reading is it's this wonderful sense
that that these symbols are being
converted into meaning in our
somehow miraculously
by our brains
using
sort of a capability that for most of
our history as as
you know beings we didn't have
and it's certainly true that that
developing the ability to read well is
one of the greatest
sort of
things that we can do to ensure that we
can be successful
you know academically professionally and
so forth reading is tremendously
powerful that's not to say that you
can't learn through experience i know
many people who are not great readers
but who
you know developed through their
experiences working with machines or
around any other kind of thing where
they accumulate
experience through watching other people
do things and then they do them
themselves and they develop a tremendous
ability which makes them very successful
human beings but reading is a shortcut
reading is tremendously powerful and
there's all kinds of uh statistics that
show that
how well we read is a bigger
indicator of
let's call it
economic social success professional
success even then the number of years
spent
in school or universities so reading is
powerful the same is true for language
learning
i like listening
it's so easy to do
i spend more time listening than
anything else because it's so easy to do
but
i realize when i sit down and read
i'm i'm gaining more words like
vocabulary acquisition
is easier through reading
than through listening at least in my
experience because
in a way the sort of visual
representation of a word
is is the written form of that word to
me rather than whatever that word
represents so it would be if it were
english red rather than the color red so
the written word is a powerful
representative of the word and if i
if i have that in my brain i find it
easier to remember vocabulary that's
part of what makes learning
persian and arabic more difficult
because i'm not yet so comfortable with
that script that i can automatically you
know call up the sort of
written representation of the word
but so reading and i say to myself i
want to do more reading and as with
all of our activities in language
learning
variety is good so i read on my ipad
using link there i can look words up i
can listen in the case of persian and
arabic where the pronunciation is not
always obvious which is also obviously
the case
in english that the pronunciation is not
obvious text to speech and i can hear
the word pronounced and that'll help me
read it so there's a number of reasons
why reading on the ipad reading in link
saving words and phrases
is an easier way for me to read but at
the same time i think it's good to read
paper books
and
when i was learning say slavic languages
even say polish or czech i would enjoy
reading paper books even romanian where
my vocabulary was more limited
because i was so familiar with the
alphabet it's more difficult for me to
do that in persian and arabic so i'm
still at the stage where i need i'm
still riding a tricycle training wheels
i'm still at the stage where i need the
assist of link looking up words hearing
the word pronounced this kind of thing
in order to enjoy reading but still
i do find that
whereas i would you know
tend to say listen to a podcast in
arabic from al jazeera now
that more and more
content
is being uh you know pushed at us on
link
in terms of things that we can import
for our own use
and a lot of that is say newspaper
articles i find it
you know quicker to just take that
newspaper article and read it in link
rather than going through the process of
grabbing a
youtube video and taking the url and
getting the mp3 file and getting it
transcribed and so forth and so on where
listening is easy and it's powerful
powerful for getting us sort of momentum
in the language for training us towards
speaking the language i associate
listening with speaking
and reading with vocabulary acquisition
of course
both are involved in both so reading
helps you speak because you're acquiring
more words
listening helps you read but
if i were to say
what what is the sort of emphasis in
listening it's speaking what is the
emphasis in reading it's vocabulary
acquisition and so
i just wanted to and i will continue
making videos about listening and the
importance of listening but i don't want
to de-emphasize reading
and uh while reading is not something
you can do while you're doing other
tasks like is the case with listening
it's something that's relatively
portable
and you can do it when you have 15
minutes or 10 minutes or you're waiting
somewhere and so you can read either
because you have a book
paper book or because you have your
iphone and you can just start reading
say in the language that you're learning
whether on link or some other
website that you're following so
reading is extremely important in
language acquisition
and um
but with that i will try to do more uh
videos in different languages about the
power of listening and if you have some
requests there please let me know thank
you for listening